hey texas new york philadelphia take the
jolly ranchers out of your ears and
listen up because the keep it moving
tour is coming your way yeah guys uh
it's a stand-up show when we play ayg
with the audience it's a good time uh
september 21st will be in san antonio
september 22nd we're going to be in
houston september 23rd to the 25th we're
going to be in austin for the moon tower
comedy festival ever heard of it
then uh dallas fort worth on september
26 and we're bringing it back up north
baby uh september 30th we're going to be
in long island
and then
what are we doing if we're going home
for cheese steaks
whiz wit baby october cheesesteaks and
vengeance october 27th we're gonna be at
helium comedy club in philadelphia get
those tickets they're gonna move fast
i'm telling you yeah do it yeah welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage oh yeah little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they grew up to be classy or
if they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day down here at in 20's
basement yeah very excited eagles first
win yesterday
could not be more excited she went out
last night she got all banged up i'm
pretty sure i saw a couple of guys from
the eagles practice squad leaving her
bedroom this morning around 6 00 a.m
yeah talk about going for two am i right
oh my god my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me unamused as usual
they're always too wordy he is the ceo
of are you garbage and a little critical
on people's creative processes
uh give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang happy to be here
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are
true the [ __ ] roof that youtube's
cooking and then what's really cooking i
mean we say it every week multiple times
talking about the greatest website on
the history of the plenary ever created
shout out to yam the yam family yeah
then patreon.com patreon.com are you
garbage you can sign up you get a bunch
of bonus content uh bonus episodes of
ayg episodes of hard feelings
live streams we do with our top tier
people it's there's live show footage up
there the whole [ __ ] nine check it
out it's good times check it out gang
and having a quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire he's the magic
man he makes us all look good give it up
for t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen holy
didn't realize i don't have a mic
i totally didn't know toby didn't have a
mic i was wondering why
i was wondering why you yelled through
the roof like that i was like oh we're
both launching it
gang we could not be more excited to
have two incredibly special guests back
with us today the first time we're doing
four people at totty's table we could
not be more excited you know them you
love them from the dad meet podcast give
me a nice big round of applause for mr
tim butterly and mr mike great
hey boys thank you boys guys uh we come
bearing gifts
i watched this podcast and i had a
sinking suspicion that you have this
thing filled with [ __ ] buttons
this is a sewing kit in a worst case
scenario
beautiful thank you shout out to trolls
bakery shrubs bakery south philadelphia
prospect prospect prospect park yeah
look at that since 1888 that's a fine
establishment
also too did you have some of these the
cellophane's off i started to unwrap it
but then everybody yelled at me to wait
do it on camera idiot that's pretty
trashy you don't unwrap when you bring
your hand i was gonna present it to you
so you can give the okay like it's a
bottle of wine
[Laughter]
should have known better chocolate
sprinkles sir yes of course it's a you
who 2021
[Laughter]
shout out to you are we you who fans at
this table by the way dude i just saw
you who can at a pizza place around the
corner
i almost threw it all away
i don't need i don't need to have any
plans wish i could drink a six pack of
years yeah is it at a fat child memorial
yeah
even though they still sold it in cans
what yeah that was what was so
surprising i i thought it was a bottle i
was a box man back in the day yeah
bottles you get your hands on them
but usually boxes in the lunchroom
that's how you did it just picture you
drinking a 40-ounce box
pouring it out for a couple of homies
that passed away at diabetes it was all
a dream
i accidentally got really close to one
of my grandmothers as a child because
she lived walking insane statement
like very close like not just distant
old person relationship because she was
walking distance and she always had
boxes of yoohoo in the fridge so she's
like i'll just pop by my mom's real
quick and god damn it worked her bait
worked yeah
she's so [ __ ] nice that's the pudgy
ones back again yeah dude also a
convicted sex offender
unfortunately i want to i want to
address you've had probably the craziest
episode of one of the craziest episodes
i thought you were digging
your sex offender i immediately think of
the reigning kevin ryan from abc news
over here
no you're you told the story of your
uncle which if you haven't listened go
back and listen real weirdo man just
taking kids to howard johnson it's
really crazy
you told that to a live live show it was
like 85 people being like what in the
[ __ ] i've started the search for a
courtroom hypnotist to get the rest
although i do know it would be a great
episode put rainey under hypnosis dude i
do know where he eats dinner every
wednesday night yeah so also the team so
the team the the fans
we could sleepers him
yeah same thing i always wanted to watch
you die uncle beave
[Laughter]
uncle b if you did things to me i was
toughening you up a little bit
you're good kids he's in chipotle
well the working theory in the youtube
comments was it was your real dad i get
that and that would be the logical
conclusion i look just like my dad
though okay however i don't know that i
mentioned this on the first episode but
i re one of my earliest memories
was of my mom going through the poconos
with uncle b for the night
and as young as i was i recognized like
all right this isn't kosher
i don't know why they went like what did
they pack him in jesus
he undoubtedly took her to howard
johnson's for hong kong
but they came back the next morning and
they brought me a drum
like a drum to play like the instrument
yep that's so a 55-gallon trash can
mike get in
holy [ __ ] jesus dude yeah i looked just
like my dad otherwise i would be fully
on board with uncle are both your
parents still alive yes have you asked
any of these questions they would never
answer they would never no if we called
them right now on air
i'm kidding i'm kidding
um i'm out front although honestly he
doesn't look too different from my
father
but if i showed you a picture of my dad
you would say so you never said have you
ever seen him and your dad in the same
room
they know each other right they were
buddies because they were spider-man
they they were volunteers at the same
fire company okay
jesus christ
this is
i forgot how insane the story was they
shared custody of a dalmatian
they were both guards at my youth
correctional system
i didn't slept in the room with me which
i thought was weird
um
holy [ __ ] i don't know yeah that that
that sex go back if you haven't listened
it was the live episode with mike rainey
and shane gillis was on it as well it
was [ __ ] he's not around anymore
uncle beave though right he's still
living as far as i know
hold on a second is that recording still
did all the power in the building just
go out
it's the spirit of uncle b we're still
running okay
keep your mouth shut
my
instead of boo he says
take some candy
mike's screaming in front of like a dark
and bathroom mirror i'm not a fat little
boy
he's beating his drum you say ice cream
man into the mirror three times
[Laughter]
damn that was weird
there's nothing more trash than getting
molested
[ __ ] loser it was just so crazy
because me and foley didn't know much
about his background and he's like oh
yeah my uncle beave used to take me on
my birthday and christmas to a motel and
give me toys right no give me this
[ __ ] cookie
man they would never they wouldn't so
you can't get any closure on any of that
there's no way if i presented that
directive a question that they would
answer i think they would probably do
that feigning goat thing where they just
fall over pretend like they're sleeping
i just flat out asthma if uncle bee was
my real dad but dude he would come he
came every christmas morning in addition
to taking me out for my birthday he
would come every christmas morning and i
think it was what did he used to drink
it was like canadian club whiskey on
christmas morning classy guy awesome
yeah it wasn't you who out of a can
is he wearing like a stained wife beater
with suspenders at the time dude not too
far off
he usually wore gray pants and a white
dress shirt and he always smelled like
um
pipe tobacco my comb
smelled like me
[Laughter]
keep those kids awake
[Laughter]
you have brothers and sisters though
right yeah i have a sister
did he shower her with any of this kind
of nothing
dude come on man dude i had a 30
spending limit every birthday he would
take me to kitty city on baltimore pike
and we would go there and i would get
what i wanted and then we'd go right to
howard johnson and then he would get he
won't yeah
he would shower you with gifts then
shower you
it's a fine line i don't know which
one's worse oh man is either child
molester or a really great guy
sorry i'm sorry you're really trying to
make things right
you're gonna have to get like m night
shyamalan to write your suicide note at
this point
i see hot dogs
that's great
boys thank you for coming and sitting
with us folks if you don't follow if you
don't listen if you don't watch the dead
meat podcast first of all your bonk goes
yeah you gotta check it out it's
absolutely amazing two of the funniest
guys absolutely likewise for sure um you
guys are the best this is a family
episode we have a little company so as
you know we'll answer your patreon
questions uh when you sign up for
patreon you get to submit a garbage
question we will read it on the air
um we were getting to everybody we got
through most of the backlog uh but we're
working on it thank you for being
patient um we love you we appreciate it
yeah some of your questions are just
kind of insane he's lying he's actually
on lemonparty.com
what's lemon party
wow what he's too old he's too old what
i want to be in come on i'll do it
i got money
they're actually a new sponsor
when you want to ask what lemon party is
the the entire mood of the room turned
sour i know everything
it's uh old gentlemen taking care of
each other yeah taking it's a lot like
it's like band of brothers uh director's
cut oh you did tell me it's old guys
banging
right yeah we were beating around the
budget a little bit yeah yeah [ __ ]
each other
yeah okay i'll check it out in my
private time it's like a rockwell
painting of three old dudes sucking each
other out
it's a tough one
that was the biggest spin on the
american gossip
in especially in like talk about the
saturday evening the motel
that was one of the things in high
school we were in like the computer lab
and for some reason that would get i
remember you telling me that what you
were allowed to go to that i guess
because it was the dot org or whatever
it did yeah it was that in
whitehouse.com oh yeah i forgot about
white house doctor i don't know what was
that it was a porn site yeah but they
bought whitehouse.com before like the
government got on the internet oh wow
that's awesome yeah those early days it
was like the wild west ladies and
gentlemen we got
it oh good [ __ ] let's get into some of
the questions this is a [ __ ] home run
this is from austin grout first time
we're here have you or anyone in your
family ever had a soul patch
they ran
i had a big corn oh i'm still going
through my corn face right
but i you know what this is as far as i
can grow it so if i could grow it any
thicker than this you would have it i
would have it yeah really yeah oh
that's a bad luck
but
ah man soul patch i think you're you
were always too cool you were always you
were very
i was not cool i was i was maybe too
pretentious for a soul patch yeah for
sure even as a child i never even saw
myself with one but like i think
there's like a level of like finance i
like how you think there's kids out
there that see themselves with a soul
patch someday
just wait till my number comes in are
you kidding me dude every fat 12 year
old that was watching smash mouth on mtv
was like i forgot about that someday i'm
gonna spike my frosted tips and grow out
my soul pads man that guy really did it
for us back in the day that guy was a
[ __ ] hero okay
holy [ __ ] i went the opposite i was
already fat so i was just like i gotta
change things before i end up like that
i gotta ride the ship uh my dad had a
soul patch like not really so like he
like showed up one day and we were me
and my brother were like what in the
future
no stash no mustache just this thing
right here i think maybe a stash maybe a
sash but then just this like no beard
i'll give you that if you got a stash in
that you're okay did you go in his porn
drawer and it's just 311 cv's
he had the conquistador he didn't have a
soul patch yeah oh so soul patches i
just thought soul patch was just this no
it's no music no mustache just that yeah
that is a soul patch i meant just
detached from the rest of the beard oh
no yeah you'd have to have everything
shaved off and just have you work at sam
ash yeah i rocked one for a little while
for about two years
really yeah right before i moved back to
new york or back to philly
yeah you had an odd you made a lot of
odd fashion
and trend choices back then he was a
volunteer [ __ ] eater
i remember when my dad switched to a
goatee
from um mustache he went from mustache
to goatee
and it was such a shift
that i remember in my head i was just
like who the [ __ ] do you think you are
yeah yeah that's sure that happens once
the divorce papers get signed
yeah back out
she got the stash of the divorce
have you ever frosted your tips
yeah i [ __ ] around with my hair really
teenager yeah
the most drastic thing that i've done to
my body is uh
what is that go to howard johnson's with
uncle b yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude i had a big crisscross phase and in
eighth grade the rappers yeah dude where
your [ __ ] tell me you wore stuff
backwards
hey
dude i was a fat child this idiot's got
a hoodie on backwards stumbling down the
hallway my eighth grade graduation
present was a starter uh pittsburgh
pirates jersey it was black with yellow
pink stripe and uh i was i was
probably counted as morbidly obese and i
had to have my mom butted up for me
every morning oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my god
that's why did those shitty teams
uh back in the day get so much love for
merchandising well dude the pirates were
good then this was 92. oh right before
they sold everybody they were they were
winning the nlp up until that year then
i think
they would play the braves yeah but they
were huge raiders gear was huge raiders
gear was huge hornet's gear oh my god
orlando magic yeah dude [ __ ] i got
jumped when i was wearing my atlanta
falcon starter jacket and somebody else
or the colors or something they got they
were just messing with us and uh the guy
came up he's like give me your jacket
and i was a gigantic fat [ __ ]
even so i stood up to him and i said no
yeah i didn't lose my jacket i got
socked though
he got hit but i kept my jacket and it
ripped when you fell over
that sucks
damn that's a bad luck you know who made
fun of me for having a soul patch do you
remember uh
hall of fame reliever goose gossage oh
yeah ended up hanging out with him
randomly one night out of a bar any [ __ ]
all over my soul pat
how bad do you have to be doing in your
career you're hanging out with this you
with a soul patch in a bar
at no point that's that's a [ __ ]
you're enough you're in a bad place if
that's you're looking down the bar and
it's you with a soul patch and that
shitty party
yeah
um little uncle hank buy you a drink
hey you know goose from top gun so do
all the geese know each other
here it seems daryl strawberry's dick
what's the deal oh god dude did you ever
watch their 30 for 30 with him and daca
it might not be a 30 for 30 but it's an
espn thing with him and doc gooden
talking about their addiction 100
percent yeah when i watched i remember
most yeah i watched it again a few
nights ago and all i could think of is
how big strawberry's dick had to have
been oh yeah just an absolute
hindrance on the base pass the technical
the technicality of what you say that is
so great you know and i sit there and it
really it blows my mind
he's doing npr voices
terry especially gross
[Laughter]
that's a great point that you brought up
there and i think about this i think
about the veins in it
the dick's got pinstripes
boys are out in the stripes today
[Laughter]
dicks were in the
throwbacks um
all right let's see here uh this is in
the same vein as this old patch does
anyone in your family have a widow's
peak which if you see a bad one there i
think they're cool
are those on purpose i thought those are
genetic yeah yeah
yeah i don't know if that was like the
forehead soul patch
getting shaved
that's you're a loser if you do that red
soul patch
once i start going can you go a little
deeper do once the hairline takes its
first hit i might shave it just do it
before it's old
look like eddie munster walking around
yes that's a soul patch yeah or i mean
that's the [ __ ] thing that's a soul
patch on the brain i think you're a fan
i think i i think i might have dressed
up as a vampire for i think we painted
one on me for halloween one time that's
that's the easy go-to yeah you painted
on it it looks great too a little white
face paint and then paint that on might
be the most successful i ever ever was
at halloween as a child were you a fat
vampire oh boy i guess so oh man i just
picture you hanging upside down and like
you could still see the red marks under
your tits
that might have been the one childhood
memory that doesn't make me grind my
teeth at night i just ruined it just
[ __ ] you took it from you just stole
one happy moment man i got to live with
dracula
man dude you had shitty halloween
costumes
oh yeah dude i remember do you remember
the ninja turtles costume with like the
plastic shell sure i mean
three hours into the first time you use
it that's cracked in half yeah and i
probably wore that for four more years i
was like
like the the pants weren't getting past
my shin bones yeah and they get real
tattered too oh yeah you look like
frankenstein after a little while i
always got my brother's leftovers
and they were always pieced together no
it was [ __ ] bad he had this run my
mom bought him like an authentic
pirate's outfit
i mean dude like the pants real bird the
whole night
the musket work
he had this [ __ ] whole setup and then
because i remember when this year
started because i got to wear that like
three years later colby jack sparrow
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
let's talk about lathe weights lathe
weights yeah i tell you what man i know
i don't look it but i do enjoy a nice
glass a nice bottle of wine i like
knowing where it's from sure i like
getting the good stuff i like getting
good price points i worked in the
service industry it's a fun cool thing
and as you get older to sign a class
sure and i dig it yeah and they really
really have it down man they're
top-notch so lathe weights wine
subscription is an easy way to bring
exciting new wines right to your
doorstep you can unbox a world of wine
with easy access to different and unus
unexpected wine makers from all over the
globe they do all the heavy lifting for
you lace weights taste over 40 000 wines
a year how do you get that job you know
what i mean
but only 600 make the cut so you enjoy
the cream of the crop let them do it
nice so you just get the good stuff you
know what i mean you have to be digging
looking here looking there comes right
to your door it's easy peasy you sound
um members save on every subscription
case they choose to take each box
includes tasting notes food pairings and
serving inspiration uh subscriptions are
flexible no commitment to continue you
can cancel online at any time it's easy
peasy now here we go for the good stuff
uh you get six amazing bottles of wine
plus two bonus bottles i love bonus two
bonus bottles and two stemless wine
glasses for 49.99 plus tax with free
delivery just text garbage that's
nothing text garbage to 64 000 to the
number 64 000 text garbage
g-a-r-b-a-g-e to 64 000 to get this
special offer
terms apply available late weights dot
com slash terms
let's talk about ladder baby oh love the
ladder boys come on in this day and age
you got people breaking ground pushing
the envelope smart phones elon musk
shaking up the market shaking up the
market and ladder is no different and
they're bringing that to the insurance
game baby yeah uh before ladder if you
wanted to get life insurance you had to
uh drive across town sit through some
sales pitch by some guy who probably had
bad breath or whatever bad time fill out
a ton of paperwork then wait 68 weeks to
find six to eight weeks to find out if
you're approved
you know you'd also receive a zillion
phone calls from agents trying to bundle
hey what do you got life what do you got
a car what do you got bo
all that's out of the window right you
know what i mean now with ladder you can
get fast affordable term life insurance
without ever leaving your home baby it's
100 digital when you apply for three
million dollars or less in coverage no
doctors no needles no paper no one's
sticking in no no no no none of that you
know what i mean
um so if you're between the ages of 20
to 60 and you need coverage you want and
you want to team up with a company
that's redeeming life insurance choose
ladder baby gotta choose ladder i'm
telling you go to ladderlife.com garbage
today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage dewey
camp let's talk about bespoke post and
that box of awesome things i love them
fellas guys and gals over there quick
story for you my eyes are a little a
little hazy because i was out went on a
little nature walk with the lady did you
brought my bespoke post hammock with us
had a little spot right there by the
river it was absolutely fantastic fall
coming in yeah you got to get your hands
on a box awesome travel outdoor grooming
whatever you want send you a nice little
box and be ready for the fall guys it's
so easy to get started just take the
quiz at box of awesome.com your answers
will help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across tons of different
categories cool stuff they hooked me up
i mean i got a knife i got you know we
got like the outdoor box so i got a
knife i got a duffel bag because i like
we travel a bunch uh i love opening the
boxes with my the cool knife they even
in my apartment i feel like look real
cool apple picked i feel i feel woodsy
you know what i mean
so it's free to sign up and you can skip
a month or cancel at any time each box
only costs 45 bucks but here's the thing
baby they have over 70 worth of gear
inside it's cool guy [ __ ] is what it is
it's cool guys stuff you you're like i
don't know where'd you get that thing
bespoke post their the box of awesome
helps you out you know i feel like a man
uh you get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
and enter the code garbage at checkout
that's g-a-r-b-a-g
at checkout that's box of awesome.com
code garbage for 20 off your first box
do it man older brothers did have some
legendary costumes dude like horrific
nightmare costumes i remember like some
of the very scary masks my older
brothers had oh two when mass mass got
one point in like the 90 late in the
turns like the technology or something
got good where they were like this is
and this is proper spirit do you think
it was slipknot
i remember i tried i was i listened to
slip and i had that album and like i
remember looking at me like this they
even scared me then i was in like sixth
grade i'm like yeah i didn't like it
it's a little dicey dude i got only
listened during the day i i used a fake
backstage pass to get to their concert
at the electric factory one time and i
was a grown man and i was so creeped out
by them that i left yeah
they don't think they're gentle with the
women either
they don't look like love makers to me
what do you think the song waiting
bleeds about
but no my brother he had all that stuff
and then one year my mom got me a
bishop's costume
what like uh like a [ __ ] catholic
bishop
oh you know what kind of [ __ ]
brutality you're faced with
and around like a child molester the
scariest costume that year the early
1980s you see white smoke coming out of
their house she's like smells good mom
what are you cooking
dressed up like cardinal o'connor and
then she [ __ ] to appease me she made
me this [ __ ] sword out of uh
cardboard and um
uh tin foil
what did that do
cutting imagine your child's ears off
against a cardinal with a sword oh my
god wow my brother rolling around
[ __ ] yeah looking like he just walked
off [ __ ] pirates of the character
movie authentic freddy krueger
yeah had actual blood dripping down and
stuff yeah and you're wearing a [ __ ]
broken ninja turtle shell
halloween sucked as a kid yeah i loved
it it's my it's literally my favorite
holiday what was nice is when you got
into the 11 or 12 year old racket where
you can just wear your [ __ ] throw on a
mask with your boys and you'd still do
all right yeah let's do a little
mischiefing oh what kind of stuff are
you into
um we used to uh the one year we rolled
around a bb gun and shot out a couple of
windows
one year
took his costume
[ __ ] had it coming
no i remember one year we
killed our neighbor's dog it was so
crazy
a little bit mischief
you know boys being boys you totally
thought we were all going to sign on
with that like oh no way
i thought these guys they were
homophobic they're like you're a [ __ ]
jerk off now dude
now remember some guy left his uh window
down when something on the hill you ever
put the car in neutral and let it roll
down yeah we did that guy came looking
for us ran up to you guys see kids
around here we're like no you [ __ ]
idiot two of you are stacked up in a
trench coat yeah i can't see how many
kids
just us old people just us old people
it's an outrage isn't it the youth today
i remember there was uh
these kids older kids in like high
school here in like junior high they had
a mazda miata and we were they were
driving by they said they were cool
someone threw like a [ __ ] snickers
bar at them like just [ __ ] pegged the
door and there was like 15 of us
and they turned around and got out and
like i was like kind of feeling i i knew
like i'm like if we act as a united
front there's no way these two kids are
beating us up so i was kind of like it
was like it was you you threw it i'm
like yeah you're a [ __ ] or something
and i turn around and it was just me and
it dude
he was like hard power i was like you
got beat up by a guy in the middle
no they were teenagers they were like 18
or like 17 years old and he punched me
square in the chest because he knew he
would [ __ ] kill me if he hit me in
the face and
dude the wind knocked that like
i'm like flopping around on the ground
as all of my friends are running away
from me i'm like
oh man it was a it was a bad look did
you get your snickers bar back fatty
just get that bite size back please we
got a i remember some friends of mine
and i got uh we took the fall for a kid
with a great white trash nickname his
name was dusty dave oh you can't come
back from that the second you get hit
with something dusty like that it's bad
[Laughter]
[ __ ] your dad was crushed to death in a
scrap yard
yeah in the cardboard compactor we had
to add dusty to your birth certificate
yeah it wasn't natural causes i can tell
you that you guys want his remains uh is
there any copper wiring in there
that number one or number two
so uh we got uh
we were surrounded in the schoolyard we
were playing in by uh the family that
ran uh the first uh poppy store in our
neighborhood
and uh they pulled guns on us and jesus
yeah and we were so confused about what
was happening we thought we were gonna
die we probably were sure you were
probably close to it probably with the
bb gun yeah yeah wait tell me the whole
what happened why did they surround so
what happened was we had to figure this
out but apparently dusty dave had uh set
fire to the trash can that they kept in
front of the poppy store okay when you
say poppy story you mean bodega puerto
rican corner story okay yeah yeah um
and yeah they were pretty miffed about
the fire in their business
yeah dude they were rooting and tooting
at us in this
we walked them to dusty dave's house we
were like dude deal with this
and uh it was the last time i ever saw
that kid i don't know
i don't know if they killed him or he
later died from heroin or whatever he
might still be kicking around i don't
know what was his mom like i don't know
if i ever i never saw her those like
those dirt ball kids in your
neighborhood you will never see their
parents no no yeah there's a reason
they're that much exactly yeah yeah like
if you see like a six-year-old like
riding around the neighborhood on a bike
like a girl's bike with his shirt off
like giving the finger to grown-ups like
yeah you will never see that kid's
parents in your entire life yeah yeah
yeah chances are there's probably just
one of them too yeah so it's like you
know the chances of seeing you could
follow one of those kids for two weeks
and never see a parent
and you complain about howard johnson's
yeah uh i had a good good nice meal
uncle beave
i love playing that game now with my
friends now that we're in our 30s it's
like
i reach out to my friends that are still
home like still live at home i'm like
whatever i'm like there's no chance that
kid's still alive like no i saw him at
the whatever you're like oh damn good
for him yeah he's down to one foot
doing good though still no parents
um all right let's see here this one is
uh from tamale krx do you currently have
a collection of two dollar bills
you do
butter
i bet you have a couple of weird
collectors no it's worse than that i
stay coins spent them
i found a collection of two dollar bills
in uh my dad's old house and i needed
them
what's a collection two three no
between that and commemorative coins and
rolls of sacagawea dollars i probably
paid for my transportation to and from
my job for like two weeks it's pretty
cool hey i get it that's fine dude the
fact that you that you broke that down
yeah as far as transportation he had a
category for soccer joey oh dude state
quarters i opened up the the the two
part the folding cardboard uh yeah map
and dump those [ __ ] out damn
yeah man don't leave don't
don't leave real currency around me man
i'm not a collector
did you have to you just don't you don't
have to
share that with your sister or anything
like that did you i hope not
yeah no she's finding out yeah she's
going to come collecting on that
the juice is running utterly legal case
[ __ ] 36.95 you owe me
dude those maps with the quarters my
stepmom thought that was gonna be our
college fund like she was like look i
got one for each of you and then like
when like tennessee would drop it was
like we'd go to the store the bet it was
it was a scene and
never panned out to [ __ ] anything
that's trashy i remember always the the
kennedy 50 cent pieces the real big ones
they would sell an infomercial oh no the
yeah yeah you'd find them floating
around you get one of those you thought
you were hot [ __ ] did you ever get the
two buggies did you ever get the 35 cent
kennedy piece with the head blown off
those those got to be worth
a million yeah so sincerely
i was like oh he knows about coins
i thought he was gonna be like oh yeah
there was a misprint on the nine or
something you know she's got 15 cents
missing i i think i might have told this
before i had one though because it came
out in 59
what conspiracy jokes we're not doing
that fine all right um i had a two
dollar bill that i found in my apartment
that like
my buddies were using for like blow or
something at the time was just there and
like i took it that's bad because i
needed it i needed the two bucks and i
went to a bodega and they're like we're
not [ __ ] taking this thing i'm like
please please he's cursed it's got like
10 bucks a coke on it man what are you
talking about you can still get nutties
off that thing i got 12 bucks here
that's a devil's dollar
that is
that's trash yeah i love two dollar
bills i love there's something cool up
here
hey it was a good time he ain't lying
uh hashtag on perks
which is my favorite social media thing
in the world for the listener rainey
you had a you were addicted to percocets
for a long time i mean it would have run
i speak about it like it was like it was
like a sports dynasty
what's that 30 for 30 coming out
oh we've been doing it on our patreon
yeah
inspired facebook posts from like the
last 20 years
it's actually a perk 30 for perk 30.
yeah yeah i had a great run man
summer 2012 until summer of 2014 i had
one of the most illustrious painkiller
runs that anyone has ever had was that
post about the cabo comedy festival real
yeah i did i got into this thing called
the cabo comedy festival
and uh it got wiped out by a hurricane
and when i got in it was just like such
a big deal to me and i was like oh this
is gonna be it but of course it was like
one of those deals where like it's like
oh you gotta pay for everything you
gotta pay to get there you gotta pay for
your hotel but i was so excited and also
under the influence of percocet and um
perks just made me a thousand times
nicer than i am naturally
so every every post on social media was
so heartfelt it was though it's being
written to like i'm in the civil war and
i'm writing to like a loved one across
the country you might not see me ever
again yeah
my dearest brother for this eddie money
cd [ __ ] rules
yeah what a run though dearest uh that
thing in my back is acting up again
could you make me an appointment
i was wondering if you could send a
carriage to the emergency room
i'm out of my pain tonic
yeah some of those posts are [ __ ]
home runs man they're so funny i i'm
afraid i've come in with mesothelioma
getting a class-action lawsuit
i slipped it and fallen in a cvs
we'll need eight immediately
please send one forever yours in
structured settlements
i hope to make it to florida one day
please alert barnes and celino to my
are you guys big florida guys
what does that mean
do i do i shop around pain clinics down
there maybe mike maybe i've kicked the
tires on a floor on a pain management
clinic yeah dude you know which
emergency room you got to stop by
tallahassee
tallahassee general my god
they are as for jose
they are loose with the pad down there
best emergency room by far west palm
beach all right they have customer
service there it's like a resort the
paint chart goes up to 100
dude to that point i actually one of my
most memorable painkiller experiences
was at celebration hospital
what's the celebration sounds like a
crack house dude come on down to
celebration hospital kids climb in the
boarded window i put on there an open
mic there
on wednesdays it's a celebration
it's chuck e cheese for dads who aren't
allowed to see their kids anymore
dude celebration hospital sounds so sad
does somebody have a birthday show there
it's perky cheese
cheese
dude i promise it's a real hospital
though but uh when i got when i got to
disney i just had surgery four days
prior and i shouldn't be getting on
disney was a big thing for you
i still love it i still love it and i
shouldn't have got on the plane but uh
more than more so than anything else i
was constipated and i was rushing to get
on the plane because they were calling
are you with your family i am okay and
uh so it's a tinge of sadness in this
one
it's not all yuck's over here
i was trying to take a [ __ ] and beat the
clock so i can get on the plane and i
ended up rupturing my disc again
so i got on the plane i was just in a
ton of pain so i'm taking a poop from
taking it down so you so you started
taking uh
painkillers
for
real reasons it was a legitimate injury
like oh really i i rupture two discs and
i had surgery pretty quickly and then i
just jumped in the river
i just thought it looked pretty fun
but one of those in a cup of coffee
really sets the day up
but when we got to disney i had to go to
the hospital so they took me to
celebration hospital and they uh is it
oh is that like disney yeah no that's
close by though that's close by yeah
it's like a guy comes in a mickey gosh
this looks pretty ruptured dr goofy will
be in a minute
oh gosh that's the worst
[Laughter]
you're gonna have a lot of free time
holy [ __ ]
celebration hospital it's not even on
the campus it's next door
it's going to be just pinocchioing
through the streets
but anyway i got there they take car
insurance there
dude they shot me up dilaudid which was
like the most intense experience i've
ever had and the nurse was kind enough
to sit there and talk disney with me um
for about a half hour
which was probably the single greatest
half power of my life
talk disney with me
hold on that's somehow darker than
getting molested yeah can we go back to
beef
i got mouse lasted
wait a minute you see go there on
vacation with your family where's the
family while you're in this hospital
they're back at the hotel i got i got
taken out of the hotel in by uh
in an ambulance
they're back at the hotel getting their
stories straight
creating an alibi making a couple calls
okay kids now you're going to throw
mommy down the steps did you did you
give a thumbs up as they were loading
mcqueen
i'll be all right
we're looking for credit
they're young dude my my kids were
[ __ ] um my son was probably like
two
two six and ten okay so six and ten they
know what's going on so this is a normal
family i don't think they know he's on
perk
they don't know drug seeking behavior
daddy riding the lightning again
brushing up vitamins
wait so
you guys go on you guys go on vacation
you have an incident on the plane your
your disc ruptures again yeah you land
and you're on vacation now was getting
on the plane and going home ever an
option
no dude we were so poor that under any
circumstance we're going to finish this
vacation because this took every dollar
that we had for like the entire year to
get there sure so we were going to do it
i think the percocet took a little bit
too
i took every dollar
every dollar he had the bike
spent all my perk money on this what are
you nuts
so you had to go into the hospital yeah
i did and they sent me right back to the
hotel but i had to take the hospital the
hotel was very nice they sent a town car
to pick me up
because my we didn't rent a car or
anything we were just going to take the
disney buses and you know cabs if need
be but i didn't have a ride back so the
hotel knew caribro yeah they were
terrific i don't know if i can
put things on here by all means i'm
promoting
career royale
[Laughter]
so they sent a town car and brought me
back in that dude i was in rough shape
for the first three days i couldn't get
out of bed um i had to have my wife
get to get the ice bucket and hold i had
to put my bird into the ice bucket and
lay sideways just so i could pee yeah
damn yeah it was bad
oh you left it oh some poor smoke was
trying to make a cocktail when it got
there oh
some guy trying to enjoy a mai tai in
his [ __ ] hotel room hakuna matata
but they were out doing the things and
you and you were laid up there yeah i
just had to lay there then by like the
man being laid up on vacation that's
pretty garbage
it was bad dude
did i get this i couldn't get out of bed
and i had eventually by the fourth day i
knew that if i could poop i would feel a
lot better so i dis-impacted myself
i made it to the bathroom and i i pulled
this this brick out of my own butthole
i did that i felt a lot better and my
buddy chris had rented a uh hover around
for me and had it delivered to the room
so i was able to take the hover around
onto the bus and i got to the magic
kingdom the fourth day
wow and you're hal you're like what 29
at this point
you're too young to be hovering 33.
yeah and talk about a disney movie huh
right there there you go get the
treatment written up on that thing the
white trash prince
god damn damn i didn't know you were a
big disney guy dude well i think a big
part of it because i was whacked on
painkillers
but i i went this summer and i've been
sober for close to five years and i
still had as much fun this year as i've
had before will you get dressed up on
the plane like at the airport sitting
like a mickey shirt um
would you be doing this without the way
the way butterflies
well every time i step one i went with
my kids you went by yourself with my
wife
who what i don't know stay home yeah
couples disney vacation leaving the kids
at home that's
what'd you tell the kids you kids stay
here we're going to toys r us we're
going to a week-long dentist office
visit
you guys probably wouldn't be into it i
mean we could get you cleanings if you
want to come all right you guys stay
with my mom we're going to an sat camp
you guys want to go
jesus but it was just like a quick
four-day trip for my wife and i and uh
yeah we went to disney what do you do
when you're down there just as a couple
we went to the parks dude we went
through the parks and then we went to
like right now you're riding
doing all that stuff yep
and by then like i was off painkillers
at that point so it was just spending
quality time with my wife she still
stopped back at celebration hospital
remember me he gave me
[Laughter]
have you ever been to like the have you
ever go to the hospital on vacation it's
typically like we were looking for like
yeah i fell cliff diving or you know
what i mean like i cut my leg hiking i
tried to take a [ __ ] on a delta flight
blew out my spinal column
my drug addiction affected me even
getting on the plane
you could have went to the hospital in
philly
oh
but dude there was we were so broke that
nothing would have stopped me from
getting on that plane
nothing
dude that's [ __ ]
dude you are [ __ ] something else
rainy well you're a trash savant yes
dude that's that's that's the summer
that we became like good buddies because
i remember shortly after that trip we
went to go see moonrise kingdom and i
had a cane remember that dude
a cane is a bad look on somebody that's
in their 30s no idea mike was very
[ __ ] up looking and we went to see
moonrise kingdom and mike had a cane and
he was walking [ __ ] up and we
accidentally both wore uh
khaki cargo shorts and black t-shirts
and
like a good third of that movie is kids
taking off their clothes and kissing
it's the closest i've ever come to
walking out of a movie
that's closer i came to olympic games
i'd leave if it wasn't for this damn
hitch in my step
apparently you get up to walk out randy
goes closer to the screen
[Laughter]
he puts his dick in his own popcorn
[Applause]
[Music]
funny i re-watched moonrise kingdom not
that long ago too it is a little dicey
that's a weird afternoon for you and
your buddy yeah
you and your new buddy who has a game
who you're dressed identical to you and
your new drug addict
for the record this was celebration
theaters
[Laughter]
oh man i like how you didn't reciprocate
what mike was like that's the summer we
became real good friends but it was like
you can't explain it i don't know what
this guy's talking about that's the
weekend i went to the mall or i went to
the movies with a sociopath
and i'll never forget this was that
summer too oh dude i got a chrysler 300
that summer too
it's the best time of my life would you
ran it or buy it i bought it dude
dude i used to get the center console on
my crusher 300 i used to keep pain
killers and pellegrinos
and tim and i have tim and i have the
reality of man
tim and i had a show at um like arts
parlor on broad street in philly and i
remember the look on your face dude when
i popped it open and i said uh
painkiller pellegrino
like tim just looked at me like
i don't understand what's happening
right now
i mean yeah well i was i don't think
anybody's ever said that sentence ever
i've never been prescribed a real
painkiller in my life i couldn't imagine
sharing one if i got it i that was that
was what i couldn't understand i was
like dude that's like that's how much i
care about you dude in the government
isn't someone gonna call you and ask
where this pill went if i take it from
you
it's funny because some people were
lucky with that [ __ ] and other people
were like you know we're like never i
think they see you they see your zip
code and they're like you think yeah
yeah i always thought the rule was that
you're going in the athlete you don't
want anything i've tried that i've tried
being desperate i've tried everything
ibuprofen 800. every single day really
yeah god tell me what you want me to
suck dude come on baby
we're going to give you tylenol with
that codeine
dude that would be a come up
all right let's see um this is from
braxton you both have kids so what's the
crumb situation under your couch
cushions at the moment [ __ ] nightmare
that's always good to ask i know what's
the crash to ask that question i i can i
can say without any doubt that that's
probably what started the chris benoit
situation
the problem situation the crumbs in my
couch are so bad that if i drop
something in the couch it's gone to me i
won't put my hand in there oh sure
really oh yeah dude you ever see that
like
a tribal initiation where they put like
a kid's hand in a glove full of fire
ants yeah that's what it feels like when
you reach into my couch
yeah that's that's your ball going into
the old nazi neighbor's yard yeah
that's
what about the back of the car
terrible at any given time if you if you
were diligent enough you could
reassemble an entire box of fruit loops
because let me tell you something i
don't mind that stuff but you know what
gets me is the sour milk smell no i
don't [ __ ] with that oh i can't do my
buddy can't smell car [ __ ] two car
seats in the back just kicking like sour
milk
are you saying milk
is that a different thing no he's that
trashy he's he says it m-e-l-k milk milk
he says hello
yeah hello did you guys have a parlor in
your house growing up not we didn't that
was our living room it was the parlor
yeah that's a that's like a roll home
thing though like yeah all of my
i grew up in the suburbs but everybody
would they referred to that room as the
parliament that's where you sat and
prayed or talked to the cops
bring them into the parliament we had
books there we had those parlors my
cousin had i'm sorry no that was it was
gonna say my cousin tracy had a
boyfriend named jimmy and uh he got into
a knife fight
and he jesus christ you get into this
all right
the guy tried to cut up jimmy's throat
and so he was wearing like this neck
brace and my cousin richie made up this
jingle about him he's like sitting in
the pilot with jimmy cuddler what the
heck which you jimmy nick
[Laughter]
who tried to cut his throat uh just like
does it matter
anybody that's fine
um all this has been we've been talking
about this how do you say
uh the product that crayola makes
how do you say that crayons crayons
crayons crowns
i think i said crayons crayons but you
think you see it's crowns
say it slowly
if well that's not that's yeah i'll nail
it if you let me say crayon you do have
a little bit of a y in there but it does
lean very crown yeah crayons
uh how's this down crayons
it sounds different doesn't have any
crowns
that's you you lean more towards crowns
i say crowns i know it's wrong crayons
he says crazy yeah crams what crayola
crayons like [ __ ] grand apple you
[ __ ]
it's crayon there's no way that's not
the you hear the why in there that's
literally how it's
crayons that's supposed to know why
really hard crazy there's not a person
on earth that would hand you the correct
object if you ask for a crayon
a crayon do you have any crayons crayons
like our hands i'd ask if you were
hungry cranes yeah i think i stopped
buying them i think i got some apricots
crayons yeah i don't think so pop-tarts
yeah dude wow that's like
and how adamant he is about it is is
crazy yeah it's authoritative
crayon
yeah crayons for the kids i mean i know
i don't say it right but i admit it i
say it wrong you're dead i don't think
it's crayons you think if you walk to
the crayola factory and you'd be like
hey look at all these crayons they'd all
go oh we know what he's talking about if
he goes his mouth is going to be
probably like what the [ __ ] you doing
that's great i still don't know i think
no i i am doing the y i'm doing crayons
no that's not how you say crayons you
say
sorry you say c-r-a-n-s crayons i don't
think so
crayon i i think he just started the
crayons rights movement there you go
how about that
yeah that's the [ __ ]
what else that's going to do or
something dude that word is going to hit
me in the back of the head driving home
lately yeah was he really saying crayons
yeah crayons
crayola
see what you did
crayola
crayons your tongue's fighting bad man
i'm not gonna do it i got a wisdom tooth
fighting me oh man that's a [ __ ]
great one i don't think so i don't think
anything's wrong with milk either milk
how do you say milk with an eye say it
milk
oh big chap
like
god intended yeah milk
excuse me president you pronounce words
like you're fighting for custody with
your tongue
[Laughter]
he got partial custody of his own mouth
state took the rest all right this one's
fun this is just funny this is from
michael anybody in your family named
lenny
lenny dykstra hangs out at a bar by my
house now really
he lost it dolan's pub in ridley he
hangs out yeah was he the guy that got
like airplanes repossessed from him yeah
he was killing it for a while
yeah he was doing all right he was happy
he made a lot of money in la in
california
car washes yeah apparently like car
washes out there like uh you know you
can just print money with them i don't
know
but him and ian had a blow up didn't
they mr ian fidanz really hit the beef
with dijkstra i think they got into it i
think i think ian looked up to lenny
dykstra pretty hard growing up 100 i
can't believe you didn't know who he was
to be honest with you who lenny thanks
for yeah i know who he is i just i i
think i always because he's done so much
weird [ __ ] like i think he ran like a
failed video game company at one point
yeah oh that's uh kurt schilling
yeah that's what happens i always
confuse lenny dexter and kurt chilling
yeah yeah well they were on the same
team
yeah nails right yeah yeah yeah yeah
and dalton straight yeah they were boys
they were here
oh man they tore through philly in the
80s dijkstra convinced his wife that he
was going away to rehab but instead he
went to europe by himself for 30 days
yeah damn that's [ __ ] crazy that's
chess not checkers right there
wasn't a crook on the team as well he
was yeah
one nut that's he lost his ball that was
an entire summer of every conversation
for that summer with me and the boys was
just about having that probably you were
like 10 or whatever like and that like
blew my mind of like this guy now just
has one ball one one nutcrack was yeah
that was a great summer yeah
i was a game changer dude yeah we got a
great we have a lenny in the family you
have a lenny yeah we have a lenny you
get len or lenny
lenny full on money man or woman
man
[Laughter]
i know a female lenny you know a female
lenny yeah but are you trying to say
linny though
laura
i'm talking about hollywood actress
um all right this one's from clark ever
pumped gas into anything other than a
gas can a water bottle a bucket a cup
there's no way the two of you haven't
done this no dude any no i don't think
anything other than the portable
container yeah like the red container
yeah i think that's it no i helped the
kid uh oh god i helped the kid make
two-stroke mix
where he was he was mixing oil and
gasoline in a water bottle for sure
damn because we had a we got our hands
on uh like a motorized scooter back
before anything were electric we're
tooling around the neighborhood yeah we
filled up a water bottle with some guys
on there that's such a dirtball thing we
got our hands on one yeah not like
someone bought it or i could i would
have greedy little mitts yeah i would
never be able to tell you who actually
owned or paid for me
you boys want to make some two-strokes
did you ever run out of gas where you
had to walk in and get it what were you
throwing up the red thing for
my lawn mower that's not bad dude
running out of gas um i ran out of gas
going to work and it was very close to
my i worked at a high school this was
like 10 years ago and like that was a
man shocking but okay
that was emasculating because kids were
walking to school and then
i didn't have any money to to fill it up
then so the car was just at the gas
station so i had to walk down to the
regional rail line which was probably
like a quarter mile down the road and i
was walking and a group of kids noticed
that i was walking to the regional rail
line and one of the kids yelled out no
car have an ass
[Laughter]
[ __ ] i love that insult it's so
spot-on
were you walking on the shoulder
no it was a sidewalk
that's rare yeah
but you can tell it's just like some fat
[ __ ]
it's september
i love a guy walking on the shoulder
with a plastic bag oh yeah or yes just
always it's always a bad look and
there's they have like a fender and a
shopping cart and they're pushing it
you're like what the [ __ ] just sweating
through a van houston
oh man thank you so much those things
stink
then using button downs see right
through your nips
these things are always see-through
wear like two t-shirts
[ __ ] van use them they might be a
sponsor one day don't [ __ ] crash
we're going super corporate uh all right
this one's from chris you or anyone in
your family ever walk around on their
tippy toes on a regular basis
what the [ __ ]
there's those kids oh
hold on like they walk on the balls of
their feet rather than
we we just noticed this on a guy on tv
we were watching love island and dude
walks like that yeah but i have a very
creaky house so
i'm playing video games all night every
night sure i can't i ca i have to walk
like that after dark yeah you can't lead
with the heel yeah exactly i have to
like i have a mental map of every creek
in my house oh of course i could walk
through my house in the dark and avoid
like
and it's just because i'm i'm video game
still 2 i am every single night can you
make love that way too
like you know where to pork on the bed
a little bit to the left wow why the
kids will wake up that easily it's that
loud
i mean i'm putting some [ __ ] pressure
on the boards i'm talking about making
love to his wife
trying to think about [ __ ] his wife
here
i apologize
next question
you've lost my interest i'm so sorry
guys
you don't deserve this
wow we were talking about two different
things
a bunch of stiffs on this podcast that
all right this one's from joshua ever go
to a high school party when you were 21
or older
oh yeah
really yeah how what was the connection
to get you there let me choose my words
carefully yes please
it was just
no dude i wasn't in the drugs yet it
took me
i didn't start doing hard drugs until i
was 27.
up until then it was just um just beer
[ __ ] weed and mushrooms beer heroin
coke
[Laughter]
but this was like at a point where
my buddy brian like he he went to west
chester university and he had a house
there
and then we were at that weird age where
it was like okay some of us were 21 some
were 20 somewhere 19 and then it seemed
like the 19 year olds would bring
kids that were still in high school sure
so it was like a weird mix where it was
just like okay like
this you know
some people could validate validate
being there sure yeah yeah yeah
yeah i don't know we're just gonna take
the whole thing
no good
chaperoning
[Laughter]
did you ever go back to your high school
football games
no never never honestly i could have saw
rainey
dude i was i barely said 10 words in
high school and i was happy to get out
there it wasn't a bad experience but i
was just so painfully shy that it wasn't
gotcha but it wasn't until i started
boozing pretty hard where i started to
feel comfortable around people so in
high school i just started to hit my
stride with boozen yeah what heist would
you go to bonner
[Music]
nice
good school yeah out of bad school
where'd you go
northeast
which
how about you guys where'd you go i went
to council rock
in the bucks county isn't that where
simba was raised
everything on the other side of the
bleachers is yours
holding up kimmy's big head
took his mom and his dad
they're both doing it
he's smoking
um all right let's see
this is from kevin have you ever been in
a tug of war competition as an adult
[Laughter]
every day when he puts his pants off
goddamn belt buckle
i have that's trash
that's like wholesome where are you
doing it though yeah that's the i mean a
corporate backyards
back yo if you're doing your yards
that's worse that's crazy is it his
brother's starter jackets in the middle
i've been at like get like a
family party or like uh tim that's a bad
look if you're doing tug of wars at your
family horseshoes corn holes darts
things like that i'll give you the fight
you guys you got to be the anchor on
fourth of july that is a bad look what
nobody does that's cool we've done well
i don't know we we icelandic what's
going on i don't know we spent a lot of
time with like the kids from our jiu
jitsu gym and i think that's where that
kind of thing pops up you do look nordic
thank you
yeah you you look like you could be like
an llb model wow meanwhile like the
three of us look like we say happy
birthday to porn stars on twitter
i've always wanted to say that
wow by the way jenna jameson coming up
i don't think i forgot about it
[Laughter]
no tug of wars are not trash they're
normal and cool body i don't know that's
insane that's good
challenges are great and healthy
in gym class sure not at somebody's
[ __ ] christening i love horsing
around ted get the rope yeah physical
challenges are great i had a cousin in a
wheelchair she loved it
no
what delft they're not you're crazy yeah
give me an exact time and place where
you were at where there was there was a
tug of war i it's i i i who even has you
make it seem like they're happening so
much that you can't even pull one out
yeah yeah here in a league it's
insignificant as a memory because we i
don't yeah
his son's christening they got the baby
in the middle yeah
yeah no what okay i didn't even like him
as a kid because i was who would even
have those huge ropes nobody has those
huge ropes i don't know we spent a lot
of time with you guys hanging out the
docks a lot
a bunch of yards i hate it but at least
like genuinely upset about this i don't
know no you know what it is i hate when
i'm so off on something i'm just like
what do i know about jesus christ dude
is that coming through are you getting
that yeah
two cookies is my sweet spot
you also have farted since we've met
an hour and a half ago you farted 47
times yeah
these are like these by the way these
types of like dinner table these are
like [ __ ] batting practices marshall
amps for farts oh yeah
it's like a stack feeling van halen
it's like performing at red rocks
[Laughter]
ah legendary yeah man oh man all right
let's do a couple more this has been a
[ __ ] heater um this is from ben white
do you or anybody you know drive a crown
victoria
i think it's crazy anymore
not anymore what crap
crayon victoria
[Laughter]
crayola crayon victoria a crown
the [ __ ] spotlight in the driver's
side window yeah you're driving out
sorry yeah of a psycho yeah that's a guy
pulling kids over yeah buying a car at a
police auction
i always wanted to there was that one
when you're driving down 95. it's like
the police auction sure left we're going
south and i ever remember was like when
i turned 16 i'm going there and getting
dude just imagine if the drug dealer it
gets taken from sees you
i think that was a thing like people i
think there's stories of that where like
you buy like a purple escalade and
they're like he's like that's clearly my
[ __ ] card grimace is yelling at you
down the street
nah man i got it on the lot swear to god
i think you'd have to paint it
i had a wigger brother
who uh i think he
went from a crown vic to a i want to say
a rehab
back to the ground
sunrise rehab he had a celebrations
crown vic um it was like a big boxy
buick i want to say is riviera yeah
riviera's one yeah he had both and it's
in that same world as the crown vic
didn't the riviera have the wire wheels
uh the spokes in them a nice one would
have those things were garbage yeah but
he uh i remember it had a red like
it's not velvet
it's like a white floor
like a velour red interior yes yeah and
we we had a job together one summer i
was like 13 years old and i remember uh
we would we would run to grab like uh
sandwiches at lunch and he would smoke
weed in the car with me every day
and i was just like i don't even think
this is cool
that's the official car of getting a 19
year old pregnant yes yes
yeah they were they were any time like i
had i had a 90 my first one was a 96
chevy lumen it was the same it was just
like a big [ __ ] oafy old person's car
and at any time anytime anybody has it
i'm like oh i know the struggle you're
going through yeah i love those now
though oh they're fantastic i love a
gigantic rectangular car right now oh
fantastic what are you driving now
2019 volkswagen jetta that's pretty good
it's raining 2017 volkswagen jetta i
just want to say happy birthday in
heaven to my chrysler 300.
what happened that there's no way that
ended great
you didn't turn it in after the lease
was up we just talked about this last
night dude what was the buy-back value
on that
probably rolled out the red carpet for
you huh it got in pounders it got it oh
no no it got uh repossessed it's got a
lack of payment really dude it
something went wrong with it as to where
like the something with the transmission
and it was dirtbag
it got repo'ed and then i fell behind on
payments too it was just like what year
are we talking about with this this was
2017. so
like april 2017. okay and then in the
middle of the night one time like my
wife and i we were asleep downstairs in
the living room and she my wife woke me
up she's like like there's somebody on
the steps
and i look at him why were you sleeping
in the living room it's just what we did
like forever honestly watching tv yeah
yeah that was where the window ac unit
was
everybody was in the living room there
was a mattress on the floor
so me and 30 other people were sleeping
all right and then uh i opened the door
i was like can i help you he's like yeah
dude i'm sorry to do this but i'm here
for hang on what time of night is it
dude it was like three in the morning
dude you open up the door with
you knew exactly what was going on keys
percocet
center pellegrino no thank you i've
already helped myself
but uh he was like what a gentleman you
are about it yes hello he was as cool as
can be about it and he's like do you
have the key and i said i gave it to him
they they towed it away and that was the
last that i saw it one day i'm gonna
treat myself to one again you're gonna
buy that's like that's the thing that's
the how long had you not been making
payments on it
since probably september so it took a
while
this was spring okay
damn that's pretty good yeah so you
cruise through
like did you ever like back it in to
like not show the plate or do you ever
try to hide it honestly dude i i have a
driveway but i started parking it on the
street because i figured that was
inevitable and i wanted to save the
embarrassment of just having a tow truck
back into my driveway sure i just
figured if i left it at the end of the
block man
i get it i get it
so you knew for this just hanging over
your head for uh for a while dude the
fall the winter and a little bit of
spring follow you know how they say like
twins can feel one another's pain like
yeah i could feel my car
getting like getting feeling the bond
being broken and that can be that could
have happened at any moment right like
you that was as you were waiting on that
to happen yeah did any part of you think
you were ever going to turn it were you
like hey if one if these next two three
things fall fall that's a shitload of
people
i i did because this probably happened
this was probably i would say april and
in may we were filming the delca proper
pilot so i knew that money was going to
come for that nice and i think that
check was probably like like a little
over two grand
and my my plans were like all right if i
can just stretch it out like a little
bit longer i'm going to use an entire
check to pay my car off and pay enough
to just keep it keep it going
but
i knew like i'd stretch it far enough
man didn't you didn't you have the car
for like five years i did dude how long
was the loan i got it
i got my pain killer summer 70-year loan
yeah
what were the payments a month
i had a reverse car loan
i'm upside down on this price of 300
right now tom selleck son of a [ __ ] got
me it cost me more to sell it than kill
myself
my kids are gonna be paying this thing
off
holy [ __ ] dude the payment was probably
like i think it was like 340 or 360 a
month oh my god what is that a lot for
chrysler what yeah [ __ ] five years
ago i didn't get like a jeep cherokee
for that that was crazy
well he did it he did it no money down
no credit check right yeah driving sign
deal or something yeah yeah
it was a payday car loan
paid 17 000 interest
oh holy [ __ ] dude you had it
was that
it was not an indian casino i couldn't
get that out
because they played by their own banking
rules holy [ __ ] oh my god
yeah let's wrap it that's [ __ ]
fantastic dude guys you're absolutely
fantastic we love you guys very much
thank you for sticking with us thank
gang you gotta check out that meat you
got anything that's coming up you want
to let them know yeah plug it away yeah
i have a new podcast with jake matera
and john del carlo called little
stinkers um if you love serial killers
and just awful people who also happen to
be very funny people check out little
stinkers
uh and also follow my twitch it's
twitch.tv slash tim butterly and it's a
really nice time that we have with the
chat and uh there's some video games and
there's some you know just uh
loser wholesomeness uh tuesday thursday
nights and sunday mornings is my
favorite one
um and would love to see you there can i
just add something real quick about that
please of course the gentleman from
philadelphia yeah yeah yeah he's so well
spoken
and then just like talks about his perk
addiction gentlemen if i may
no i just want to say that um being able
to do this is i i feel like the luckiest
guy in the world but also i just want to
say to you being able to do dad meet
with you has been probably the greatest
creative experience i've had and i just
want to thank you oh my god
rainey's back on purpose
somebody check this kid's pocket man so
i just want to say like if it's tim and
i started dad me and it was just uh
based out of like just earnestness and
us trying to build ourselves up and
trying to have better lives while also
just showcasing what morons we wear so
if that describes you and describes like
what you're going through and you're
trying to move yourself through life and
you feel like you can identify something
within us i promise you if you watch and
you like come jokes it's it's you're
going to drown and come listening
but i promise you if you can identify
with any of that check out that meat
that's great thank you for watching
can't wait to have you guys down yeah
for sure we can't wait to be on that
we'll do it for sure guys check out
their youtube check out their patreon
their patreon [ __ ] cooking check it
out support them they're [ __ ]
hilarious go back and watch their
episodes of ayg if you haven't uh i'm at
kevrant comedy on all social media
uh check out a [ __ ] live show you get
some [ __ ] merch the patreon the
[ __ ] youtube you know the deal thanks
for all the support we love you guys
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week